à quelle drogue avez-vous toujours été
fidèle
alors Jean-Michel 56 ans ouais toujours
aussi juvénile ouais il faut voir
l'intérieur
c'est très bien préservé vous buvez pas
un peu un peu quand même ouais vous
fumez pas ça dépend quoi
et un peu aussi tu notes Laurent régime
pas franchement non non
pas trop non plus pas trop de botox
pas trop mais c'est quoi alors le secret
de votre
maman aide-moi dis-leur elle a 90 ans la
semaine prochaine elle court comme un
lapin
je sais que c'est embêtant j'y peux rien
je suis désolé mais que ce soit moi ma
mère ou mon père d'ailleurs ils sont ils
sont plutôt en bonne forme ouais j'ai un
mail pour vous Jean-Michel ouais un mail
dise la belle à Gianni ouais
Jean-Michel
où tu as foutu mon petit pull marine
mon petit pull marine je t'embrasse elle
jusqu'au point de vue en retour plus
tous les mythes de notre amour c'était
l'affaire de l'été là ça a été comme
quanta et Trintignant l'année d'avant
quand même se calmer
d'occuper autant de place alors qu'il y
a des choses qui sont un peu plus graves
qui se passent dans le monde donc
j'avais un peu honte quand même j'ai
bien pris la tête de tout le monde la
mienne aussi ouais j'imagine alors
l'histoire on la connaît donc deux ans
après avoir fait la Une de match
ensemble pour annoncer votre liaison
Isabelle Adjani seul Yann annonce votre
rupture
puis elle explique que vous êtes un
pervers relationnel qu'il a trompé
depuis six mois et qui tentait de la
détruire comme il l'avait tenté déjà
auparavant de détruire Charlotte
Rampling ça doit faire drôle de dire ça
dans le journal non oui c'est plutôt
choquant ça fait ça ça abîme ça fait de
la peine aussi par rapport au fait de
mettre de mettre en cause Charlotte
aussi avec qui j'ai vécu 20 ans il y a
très heureuse et avec qui depuis
j'entretiens de les meilleures relations
du monde on est très très lié très amis
donc ça nous a beaucoup tous affectés
mais dans ce cas là le clan se resserre
donc on survit quand même alors la
semaine suivante changement de ton
c'est-à-dire c'est plus une femme
blessée c'est dans elle c'est la dignité
d'une femme pourquoi je témoigne donc là
ça prend un tour déjà un petit peu plus
hautain et puis la semaine d'après alors
là c'est le comble dans l'Express
Isabelle Adjani explique qu'elle veut
briser le tabou de l'infidélité
masculine il faut libérer la parole des
femmes sur ce phénomène de société alors
là vous devenez le symbole national de
l'homme infidèle quoi c'est plus
seulement une histoire qui tourne mal là
j'ai toujours pas bien compris
d'ailleurs tout ça c'est d'une part mais
moi j'ai décidé depuis le départ de pas
faire de commentaires comme vous le
savez dans dans la presse enfin c'est
désagréable de déjà de mettre cette
détailler sa vie privée en public mais
son intimité en public c'est encore pire
je dirais et que donc j'ai décidé
d'ailleurs par respect pour elle de ne
pas répondre j'ai évidemment une autre
version des faits et en ce qui concerne
le fait de diriger un cas particulier en
en
prétexte pour aborder un thème comme
celui de la fidélité me semble enfin ne
semble pas du tout concern tout
simplement donc là à cause de vous je
dirais ou grâce à vous elle est partie
dans dans un combat national elle veut
faire changer la loi française qui ne
reconnaît pas la cruauté mentale ni le
harcèlement moral dans le cadre privé
c'est vrai qu'au travail on peut accuser
quelqu'un de voir ce lait dans la vie
privée ça n'existe pas donc peut-être
que grâce à vous
j'espère que ça peut peut-être servir
je voudrais quand même dire que
dans une histoire
[Rires]
on va dire le mal voilà donc
je veux simplement dire que je pense que
dans une histoire comme toute l'histoire
je pense que tout le monde l'aura
compris via que quand une relation
démarre on a on a simplement on espère
tous les deux que les choses aillent
bien et finalement il n'y a pas de
bourreau de victimes de gentils ou de
méchants c'est tout à fait c'est triste
qu'une relation
qu'on espère durer ne dure pas je pense
qu'en l'occurrence il y a pas de
responsable il y en a toujours deux ou
deux responsables ou de victimes mais je
me sens pas du tout dans mon rôle à
aucun moment dans un rôle de pervers de
manipulation de manipulateur c'est pas
du tout comme ça que j'ai vécu et je me
sens absolument pas concerné ce que vous
dites si on n'était pas marié on n'avait
pas d'enfants donc il y a pas de
problème quoi c'est une histoire entre
deux adultes au bord de la route avec
quatre avec quatre enfants etc bon là on
est pas marié on n'a pas d'enfants et ce
qui m'a affecté surtout c'est de c'est
qu'on puisse mettre en doute un des
chapitre important de ma vie qui est la
relation avec Charlotte qui s'est on est
resté marié 20 ans
très bien et on est très proche
aujourd'hui donc il faut pas il faut
comparer ce qu'il y a de comparable
c'est différent on va dire alors vous
dites le harceler c'est moi quand même
parce que vous dites c'est un peu
liaison fatale l'histoire quand même non
c'est vrai que ça a été un peu lourd
c'est vrai que c'était un peu a été un
peu pénible et que j'ai eu j'ai eu un
peu honte d'occuper et que toute cette
affaire occupe autant de place il y a un
truc sur lequel j'étais moins d'accord
tous les deux c'est que vous vous dites
elle fait ça pour se faire de la promo
parce qu'elle réussit pas très bien au
cinéma et elle dit il fait ça parce
qu'il sort un 10 quoi donc vous êtes
d'accord sur le fait de vous accuser
mutuellement de faire ça pour la
promotion déjà pas mal pas du tout moi
je moi je veux dire que j'ai deux j'ai
deux actualités effectivement
à la rentrée
en ce qui en ce qui me concerne j'ai pas
besoin de ça j'ai jamais eu besoin de ça
et je pensais plutôt gênant la preuve
d'ailleurs c'est que je viens dans cette
émission et que on commence par parler
de ça donc c'est pas venu pour ça donc
c'est plutôt une chose qui est gênante
quand on a une actualité plutôt que pas
je pense que c'est c'est en revanche
quand on en a pas c'est peut-être
confortable dans tous les cas l'affaire
Jean-Michel a pris un tour plan aire
puisque c'est le New York pause qui a
annoncé que vous étiez avec Anne
Parillaud maintenant
je suis désolé vous avez lu l'interview
de ne pas rire ce matin dans le Parisien
non j'ai pas la lumière
alors justement on va parler du nouvel
album qui s'appelle Aero qui est sorti
cette semaine chez Warner et qui fait
montre d'une avancée technologique comme
comme souvent avec vous d'ailleurs alors
à l'origine c'était un projet qui a été
exclusivement musical
sans image donc et puis comme il y a un
DVD vous avez décidé de mettre une image
au lieu de faire plein de petits clips
comme ça qui ont été illustratives ça
aurait pas été bien vous avez une grande
idée que vous allez nous expliquer
Jean-Michel c'est vrai que de sur un
projet qui est avant tout musical plutôt
que d'avoir une série de clips qui est
qui est un contenu narratif j'ai essayé
de trouver quelque chose qui soit à la
fois personnel à la fois universelle qui
soit qui soit en fait qui ne dérange pas
le fait de pouvoir créer ses propres
images comme quand on écoute c'est une
très bonne idée c'est une idée
warolienne alors il va l'expliquer il va
l'expliquer
ils avaient filmé un mec qui dormait
pendant 8 heures et là c'est un regard
pendant 75 minutes c'est le regard Anne
Parillaud on a ça dans un coin de son
salon on le regarde à Paris haut c'est
très agréable
avoir un rot et hop on leur fait
[Rires]
justement tiens Jean-Michel justement il
va faire un concert à Pékin le 10
octobre vous le porterez ça bien sûr
ce sera le premier concert en 5 ans ça
aussi bien entendu voilà ce qu'il y aura
des il y aura des hauts partout assez
différent de ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à
maintenant qui est donc se situe devant
la Cité Interdite et avec
des écrans qui sont dans différents
endroits de Pékin dont le sud de la
place tienne elle-même et
donc qui est diffusé en 5 ans et qui est
qui a aussi ceci de particulier puisque
il y a énormément de sociétés françaises
qui qui soutiennent toute cette année de
la France en Chine et notamment Thomson
et le aussi bien sur le plan de la
scénographie que sur le plan de la
retransmission la retransmission va
avoir lieu aux définitions et aussi bien
en direct d'ailleurs en Chine c'est une
première qu'en Europe et on aura le
c'est retransmis en Chine
place
gêné par la nature du régime chinois non
moi je suis allé dans les années 80
j'étais le premier artiste occidental à
jouer là-bas juste après la chute de la
bande des quatre je connais bien les
milieux intellectuels et artistiques
chinois de depuis et quand on m'a
proposé ce projet je suis allé je suis
allé à Pékin pour justement un petit peu
me rendre compte de
l'état des choses et c'est vrai qu'il y
a des choses qui
qui ne vont pas encore comme on le
souhaiterait mais j'ai reçu le soutien
de la totalité des intellectuels
décrivain comme d’ici Jay comme souci
comme des musiciens des cinéastes qui
ont tous envie aussi de reprendre un peu
la main dans dans la capitale soit on va
là-bas et on les laisse pas isoler c'est
ce que vous faites bien sûr soit on y va
pas parce que quand même en Chine il y a
des camps de concentration quand même
bien sûr depuis le départ aussi qui
attaque le marché chinois qui est un
marché incroyable c'est aussi des
surtout pour les pirates
qui est souvent
disons que au-delà au-delà de ça je
crois que effectivement il y a deux
attitudes comme le disait Thierry il y
en a une qui consiste à rester chez soi
et à se dire tant que les choses ne sont
pas comme nous on pense qu'elles doivent
être dans un pays en plus que je
rappelle d'un millier près d'un milliard
et demi de gens donc les choses sont
forcément un peu différentes et à ce
moment-là bah finalement ça change pas
trop les choses qu'il faut bien se dire
que pour nous pour pour la Chine nous on
est un peu Monaco donc notre opinion
compte pas beaucoup puis il y a une
autre attitude qui consiste à aller
là-bas et puis à communiquer à rester
quand même attentif à ne pas non plus se
laisser aveugler par un certain nombre
de choses et je crois que c'est le but
de l'année de la France en Chine c'est
convaincu non pas trop non mais il y
avait quand même beaucoup de gens ici
qui était je pense que c'est bien
d'aller dans un pays et de pas attendre
que les choses changent pour pour y
aller mais c'est bien si on veut un peu
noyauter le pays et puis et puis quitte
à faire des esclanes ou des des
accidents diplomatiques mais de profiter
du fait d'être là-bas pour dire à voix
haute chose qu'on a pas le droit de dire
là-bas oui mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que
non mais ça ils s'en foutent je veux
dire que l'opinion de la France
franchement ça compte malheureusement
pas beaucoup et je pense que c'est très
très important je pense que justement il
faut y aller pour pouvoir l'exprimer
pour pouvoir justement aider aussi de
l'extérieur ce que les artistes chinois
puissent s'exprimer donc c'est aussi ça
le problème et je pense que il faut
faire attention de ne pas être de ne pas
avoir un rapport avec les Chinois
décaler c'est qu'on a on a un certain
moment été maoïs aussi au moment où Mao
déportait des millions de gens donc il
faut faire attention de pas toujours
avoir une idée depuis une idée préconçue
de la Chine depuis le Café de Flore je
pense que c'est important d'y aller et
puis de rester les yeux ouverts de ne
pas être naïf et d'être attentif vous
partez avec votre maman
on va fêter ces 90 ans à Pékin
c'est quelqu'un qui ouvre sa gueule
pendant la guerre elle était dans les
dans les frontières de la région de Lyon
était dans les camps donc elle sait de
quoi ensuite elle a été déporté à
Ravensbrück elle sait qu'on parle là les
camps les a connu tout à fait et donc je
suis très très fier à très heureux
qu'elle puisse venir et qu'on puisse
justement fêter son anniversaire à Pékin
alors je disais récemment dans la presse
parler de votre père Maurice Jarre et
vous disiez que ça allait pas mieux
finalement 40 ans après un moment c'est
un peu mieux parce qu'il s'intéressait à
votre fils mais quand même j'ai pas trop
envie de parler de ça parce que
finalement les choses les choses se
passent pas si mal que ça c'est vrai que
quand on quand on vit très loin d'un
d'un des parents et finalement l'absence
ou la béance c'est pire que le conflit
et que on se dit finalement c'est
peut-être pas mal que on regrette
peut-être que son père vous ait pas mis
sa main sur la gueule parce que ça au
moins c'est un c'est un vrai c'est un
vrai contact au moins et que quand ça a
pas lieu c'est vrai que c'est lourd à
porter mais finalement les choses
s'arrangent et puis je pense que elles
vont elles vont s'arranger enfin en tout
cas c'est ce que je dis un truc dont
vous êtes parmi ça
c'est très difficile parce que
finalement quand
finalement si vous avez un parent un des
parents ce que je ne souhaite évidemment
à personne mais qui meurt vous en faites
le deuil
l'absence c'est un peu la différence
donc on n'a pas tellement de manières de
prendre ça enfin moi j'ai eu du mal mais
en fait en même temps je n'en veux pas
c'est l'histoire des parents au bout
d'un moment on juge pas en juge pas son
père ou sa mère c'est d'ailleurs
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est c'est
d'ailleurs l'erreur qu'on fait on
choisit pas ses parents on choisit pas
sa famille non c'est vrai Maxime Le
Forestier
[Rires]
c'est pas sûr qu'on choisisse pas ses
parents le discussion alors Jean-Michel
Jarre Isabelle Adjani a fait de vous
donc on le disait tout à l'heure
l'étendardes de l'infidélité en fait
vous êtes assez fidèle contrairement à
ce qu'elle dit j'ai toujours pas compris
parce que vous êtes resté quand même 20
ans avec Charlotte Rampling et ce qui
n'était pas d'ailleurs un record ce qui
était extrêmement agréable et c'est pas
assez long quand même oui c'est long et
puis surtout vous êtes restés 30 ans
dans votre ancienne maison de disque
Dreyfus avant Warner qui est votre
nouvelle maison 10 donc ça fait quand
même des longues périodes quoi oui non
c'est pour ça que je me sens absolument
pas concerné par par cette histoire de
par cette histoire de toute façon mais
bon je vous trouve assez fidèle il est
pas très étonnant qu'on fasse une
interview fidélité absolue
[Musique]
à quel groupe de rock avez-vous toujours
été fidèle Led Zeppelin à quel chanteur
avez-vous toujours été fidèle John
Lennon
il y en a d'autres ouais
pour l'anniversaire de mes 10 ans je
traînais dans un petit bar de la voilà
et au chat qui pêche et Chet Baker m'a
joué de la trompette pour mon
anniversaire comme ça parce que le gosse
qui traînait dans la dans la boîte et
c'est aussi un de mes grands souvenirs
de musique en fait le chat qui pêche
était dirigé par une bonne femme que
votre mère avait connu dans les camps en
prison ça fait numericard et qui a
ouvert le chat qui pêche qui était la
boîte de jazz moderne après la guerre
dans lequel dans laquelle c'est ce
produit des ailes et les gens comme
tonne Cherry John Coltrane donne chérie
le père de Néné chérie absolument voilà
et Chet Baker donc à quelle femme
avez-vous toujours été fidèle
à ma mère bonne réponse à quelle
maîtresse avez-vous toujours été fidèle
à ma maîtresse de CM2
à quelle conviction religieuse
allez-vous toujours été fidèle il y a
quelque chose là-haut qui est de moins
en moins près de moins en moins précis
mais dont je suis de plus en plus sûr
à quelle boîte de nuit avez-vous
toujours été fidèle j'aurais envie de
dire le marquis club à Londres dans les
années
club qui dont je suis toujours resté
fidèle par le par le cœur en tout cas
parce que c'est la première c'est la
première le premier club où je me suis
produit quand je devais avoir 14 ans il
y avait un groupe qui passait derrière
qui était pas très connu qui dans lequel
il y avait
Jimmy Page Eric Clapton etc un an après
c'était hier Birds donc c'est un truc
qui m'a marqué et vous c'était les deux
binds voilà exactement
à quelle drogue avez-vous toujours été
fidèle
la douce
à quelle pratique sexuelle êtes-vous
toujours été fidèle
la masturbation ça vous plaît ça c'est
bien tu préfères quand tu es tout seul
quoi tu es plus détendu ça dépend j'ai
pas dit que parce que la masturbation ce
ne se pratique pas seulement en
solitaire
c'est le nanisme
Laurent et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu